So, these are scary times
but unfortunately there's
more to worry about
than just a global pandemic.
New warning from the FBI
about coronavirus scams.
Scams related to the coronavirus.
Stealing sensitive personal information.
It could infect your computer.
Any time there's a global event,
hackers like to weaponize it.
So whether it's the
Olympics or an election
or a global pandemic,
hackers are trying to leverage
whatever the situation is
against users.
I have an old email address
with a pretty good spam filter
and it's just inundated with spam mail
claiming to be everything from
the World Health Organization
to COVID-19 vaccines.
Now I'm not gonna take the bait
but believe it or not,
a lot of people will.
It is working that is why
hackers and criminal
attackers continue to use it.
Now I don't need to tell you.
Well, maybe I should.
Don't click a link,
don't open attachments.
Just delete it.
But for many, that's
easier said than done.
Phishing emails have quadrupled
since the coronavirus outbreak.
It's gotten so bad that
both the U.S. and the U.K.
Have issued joint warnings
about the schemes.
So why have all these phishing schemes
pivoted to coronavirus
practically overnight?
So a successful phishing campaign,
it has to be interesting
and it has to sort of look reliable.
On one hand, they want
this email to look like
something you're gonna get anyway
but they also want it to
grab people's attention
to say Oh I need to click on this urgently
and the coronavirus stuff really
fits both of those things.
People are getting an incredible
amount of email about it
but it's also a place where
people have a lot of hunger
for new information.
But there's one ingredient
that COVID-19 pandemic
offers hackers that say a
Nigerian prince never could.
Fear.
It is scary.
Millions who are scared right now.
I am just afraid of this week.
The idea behind these schemes
is that in times of crisis
or uncertainty or fear,
people just let their guards down.
So in cases where you know
something is promised,
maybe people are distracted
and not as focused on
who might be sending something.
Or in cases where a hacker
is promising information,
when we're scared, we might
be more likely to click on it
without thinking twice about
who it might be coming from.
On top of the fear-based COVID-19 schemes,
hackers have seized on one of
their tried and true lures,
money.
The prospect of a payout
from the two trillion dollars
stimulus package in the U.S.
comes with the subject line saying
COVID-19 payment.
Again, delete it.
So it's important to understand
who these hackers are
and despite all the stock
footage ever made about hackers,
they're not necessarily
some shady dude in a hoodie.
These are folks that aren't out
to sort of make a quick buck.
Some of these groups can make
hundreds of millions of dollars in a year
and sort of have the investments
to sort of use that money to reinvest
in sort of grow big capabilities.
Cybersecurity data suggests
that many of these hacking operations
are backed by major nation states.
So we've seen multiple state-sponsored
cyber espionage actors who
use coronavirus as a lure.
We've seen North Korea, China and Russia
all employ it to try to
compromise their victims.
And it doesn't stop at spam mail.
Fake social media accounts
are spreading disinformation
about the coronavirus
that back the interest
of countries like China and Russia.
According to the U.S. State Department,
Russia has put forth its
entire disinformation apparatus
to spread disinformation about
the coronavirus pandemic.
So this includes websites,
conventional media
and also they stay swarms of
bots on social media platforms
that are doing the work of amplifying
or spreading messages that are
false related to the pandemic
Russia's motivation is to
sow discord and distrust
and are leveraging the pandemic to create
a lot of fear and uncertainty
and make people doubt
healthcare institutions.
Just because the 2016
election came to an end
doesn't mean that disinformation campaigns
from nation state actors
and criminal actors
didn't come to an end.
So we are seeing bot nets
from Russia, from Iran,
from China,
perfectly willing and capable
of creating chaos through misinformation.
And unfortunately, it kind of gets worse
because hospitals and medical institutions
are a favorite target for hackers.
What they will do is hit
a target with ransomware
which is an attack that uses malware
to encrypt or lock down data
belonging to an organization.
And they'll charge a ransom for
the decryption of that data.
And from a criminal perspective,
those attacks might be more successful
during a time when healthcare
institutions are so important.
There is increased targeting
on medical facilities,
hospitals, testing centers,
primary care physicians
because they are so dire, so desperate
to keep their operations up.
If they shut down, there
are lives at stake.
Just as we must band together
to defeat the COVID-19 pandemic,
we must also be vigilant
against the people and nations
shamelessly trying to capitalize
on these trying times.
In terms of disinformation campaigns,
it's important to think about
who you're receiving information from,
trusting official
sources and not believing
everything that's on social
media about the pandemic.
Instead, going to trusted news outlets.
Always be on the lookout to communication
that you don't normally get.
Sort of the ways to check
that you can double check
who the sender is from,
making sure they're exactly
sort of who you're expecting.
Just opening and looking at an email
in your Gmail browser is
it's gonna be very unlikely to infect you.
But your risk increases a lot
when you open an attachment
or click on a link.
So you can generally
read an email and be okay
but be very wary of attachments or links
especially if they're unexpected.
So while we all understand
the temptation to click,
out of fear or even greed,
please do yourself a
favor and just delete it.